- I'm gonna struggle
to the day I die
of allowing yourself to
look at glass half empty.
I just feel like,
now I understand, it's DNA
and it's wiring and if you
grow up with a mother
who's extremely negative,
it's a really tough situation
to break out of.
It's just proven.
I've understood.
You grow up in a
tough town, I get it.
There's a couple of
issues with that.
Number one,
everybody's got stuff.
The problem is nobody cares.
Once you understand
that nobody cares
and you're
complaining to empty air
you start going in a little
bit of a different direction
and, yeah, I try to,
I like putting out positivity.
The small minority of people
that are mad and angry
and hateful and
dark are much louder
than the big
percentage of us that
are happy and
excited and feel great.
And because the
way technology works
they are much louder than
they've ever been before.
And so I feel like
as somebody who's got
full of bright
light and happiness
that I need to start getting
louder about that as well
'cause that's the only way
we're gonna combat it.
(applause)
If that's the thing that's
gonna get the loudest
claps so far from
this conversation,
that's what we need
to be focusing on.
I feel more responsibility than
ever as somebody who is happy
and wants other people
to be happy genuinely.
If you leave with
anything for any of us
please take on a
sense of responsibility
that if you've got good
and you feel good
to start sharing
that content as well
because the world
needs more of it.
(light music)